(upbeat instrumental music)
- You took-
- Yeah.
- Penis pills.
- I took a penis pill.
- Why take these pills?
- I really just wanted to see
what it would be like
to get a chemical boner.
- Just kind of wanted
to put a little
extra something in
there, you know.
- I buy this one that has a
big gorilla picture on it.
- Do you know that
gorillas actually have
penises that are this small?
- Uh...
- You just thought these
pills would make your penis
one of those, like,
inflatable things
outside a car
dealership, just like,
make people come to
your boners, like...
- I forget what kind
they were, but, uh...
- Would you remember
if you heard it?
- Probably so.
- Okay, was it Semen Strong?
- No.
- Max Load?
- Bone Sweet Bone?
- No, it wasn't Bone Sweet Bone.
- Was it Jizz
Cannon Overspew Y2K?
Flaunty Python?
Was it Dick Hole Sun?
- No, I don't...
- Won't you come?
- Me, come?
- ♪ Wash away...
Planet Girth?
What about Oooh, You Nasty?
Boi-yoi-yoi-yoing Colossal?
Jerk du So Laid?
Ween Bay Packers?
Dick van Dyke?
Was it Executive
Produce by Dick Wolf?
- I don't think so.
- Walker, Texas Dangler?
- No.
- Was it Knock
Knock? Who's There?
- No, no, it wasn't.
- You're not, I'm not done.
It's a long name.
Oh, was it Jizz based on
the novel Balls by Sapphire?
Was it Mmmmfff?
Was it "Hey Ladies, How Are Ya"?
- Uh, no.
- Okay.
Do you know what's
in these pills?
- No.
- Do you care?
You don't know what's
in those pills.
- Oh, yeah, true that.
- I do remember one chemical.
It was ...
- Did you even look at what
was inside these pills?
- No, I didn't, you know?
- Yeah, that makes sense.
Why not go get a
prescription for something
that is actually regulated?
- Seems like a lot of effort.
- Get Obamacare.
- Will he give me erections?
- Go see a real doctor.
Okay, Dr. Drew, in your
professional opinion,
what do you think of these
gas station dick pills?
- At best, a waste of time.
At worst, dangerous.
- Do you know what exactly
is in these pills besides-
- There's a lot of stuff.
You know, there's
something we used to use
back in the day when
I was first practicing
called Yohimbine.
- Isn't that the name of
the gorilla that they shot?
What kind of dangers?
- It's like any
other supplement.
The problem being,
though, you don't know
when you're going to get
some adulterating agent
in there that could
harm you, in which case
you could really get
serious complications.
You can get something
called priapism.
- Which is...
- Which is a sustained,
painful erection
that does not go away.
- Okay.
- You can need a surgery
where they literally
have to splay the penis
to relieve the pressure.
Whenever I want to get
young men to do anything,
I just tell them it's going
to affect their schlongs.
- Yeah, what about
you, though, Dr. Drew?
- Yeah.
- When you were young and
dumb and full of questions.
- Yeah.
- Did you ever say,
"Hey, I'm going to do
"something like this.
"I'm going to try this."
- Hmm, we're really
going to get into this.
First of all, had there
been such a pill around,
I probably would have taken it.
- Yeah?
- Yeah, I probably... I was
young and dumb for sure.
- Besides the splayed
penis priapism surgery,
what is the worst thing
that could happen from them?
- Worst case, you
could wind up dead.
- With a great dick.
- Mm-hmm (affirmative).
- [Voiceover] This
message brought to you
by Los Angeles Independent
Medical Providers.
- We've all been there.
You're at the checkout counter
at your gas station, 7-11,
wherever you buy
your shiny hot dogs,
and there greeting you is a
rack of mystery dick pills.
They have names like Rock
Hard Weekend, and you're like,
"All weekend?
"I have my sister's
graduation party.
"I don't want to
be hard for that."
- Your dick is not a rhino.
- If you're a young
dude with a limp dong,
you probably have
intimacy issues.
Go talk to somebody.
- I'll talk to you
about your penis.
- No, I mean like a doctor.
- I was a doctor
in my home country.
- No!
- A pill can't fix
a broken dicks.
- Because I think I
speak for everyone
when I say I'd rather
deal with a limp dick
than a dead person.
Well...
- Say no to gas
station dick pills.
It's my proudest moment.
Right here, this is it.